mary shaw had a very specific protocol
for getting revenge on the town of
raven's fair
first she came after the men that
murdered her then their wives then their
children but why was the family of
michael ashen the boy that set her off
protected for almost 70 years
you would think that they would be her
highest priority targets stick around to
the end of this video to find out why
this video is sponsored by nordvpn get
seventy percent off a three year plan by
signing up at nordvpn.comworld
beware the stare of mary shaw she had no
children
only dolls and if you see her in your
dreams be sure
you never ever scream welcome to horror
history my name is
steve buscemi and on today's horror
history we're going to be analyzing the
life and the afterlife of the antagonist
of the 2007 horror film
dead silence mary shaw in a very old
interview with bloody disgusting the
writer lee winnell said he felt
ventriloquism was underutilized in
horror movies and he was inspired to
create the character of mary after
reading about some of the world's
greatest ventriloquists
because i was reading about you know
incredible guys who
could you know drink a glass of water
and have the doll talk and
and stuff like that so that really
inspired us for the character of mary
shaw in the film who's the
the ghost ventriloquist and all the
different abilities she has
they also hilariously try to plug the
movie's website if you want to find out
more about it go to
www.deadsilencemovie.net
no the stickman got to them
to fully understand mary shaw's past
let's take it back to the birth of mary
shaw over one century ago
[Applause]
on july 26 1869 raven's fair residence
ron shaw and betsy shaw gave birth to a
daughter and named her mary young mary
had a fascination with dolls and
eventually took up the hobby of creating
them herself
in her time she created 101 traditional
dolls which included the likes of holly
kenneth gregory andy russell jerry donny
and of course
billy mary considered these dolls to be
her family and instead of getting
married and having kids she referred to
the dolls as her children i imagine her
reclusive behavior and creepy connection
to her dolls caused people in town to
bully her resulting in her becoming
mentally unhinged we've definitely
covered one of those
before and here is my lovely
doll so i actually put my actual human
hair
as a result of this mary kept a
scrapbook keeping track of the families
who had made fun of her she also used
photographs and newspaper articles to
memorize the names and faces of the
families in this small town
at some point she also began making
sketches for what she considered to be
the perfect doll
her idea was that she could create the
perfect ventriloquist puppet by using
what she referred to as existing parts
namely hollowing out a human body and
replacing the eyes and jaw to create a
life-size ventriloquist doll to do this
she cataloged hundreds of design
sketches in her scrapbook and also began
to study human anatomy and
likely taxidermy mary ended up becoming
a very talented ventriloquist and in the
glory days of the town in the 1930s she
ran a performance called the amazing
mary shaw and billy in ravens fair which
saw sold out shows at the guineol
theatre in lost lake
miri also lived backstage in the theater
that she performed at providing her a
relatively safe hiding place to continue
to develop the ideas behind her human
doll experiments
one evening mary was performing to a
packed house at the guinol and asks a
boy named henry walker to bring billy to
her from underneath his seat when she
does so she doesn't address him by his
name at first
you
but when she thanks him she reveals that
she does already know his name which
unsettles him say thank you
thank you henry is that great young man
is your name henry once her performance
begins she's called out by another boy
named michael ashen
i can't i can see your lips moving
after revealing that she knows who he is
as well young michael here doesn't think
you're a real person
she becomes very angry with him for
interrupting her but instead of getting
upset herself she channels it through
the puppets billy
i think we should show this boy just how
real i am i'm just as real as him
no i'm afraid we must go on
with the show no i'm as real as you are
i'm alone billy i'll show him listen to
me
she stares at michael during the
applause and asks him
now who's the dummy
this was a foreshadowing of what would
come next for michael because weeks
later she kidnapped him and turned him
into as far as we know her first ever
life-size ventriloquist dummy it would
appear that she also took pride in her
actions and the turmoil that it caused
the community because she documented his
disappearance in her scrapbook
because of michael's rudeness at the
theater the ashen family and many of the
other families in attendance suspected
mary shaw as the kidnapper but because
she kept michael's body hidden behind a
secret passage in her dressing room the
boy was never found
and some of the townsfolk decided to try
to take justice into their own hands the
mob consisted of men in the ashen family
as well as other families in town that
suspected mary shaw was responsible they
caught up with her and forced her to
scream so that they could cut out her
tongue which if you think about it is
like taking a basketball
player's hands or a musician's ears or a
twitch streamer's boobs mary's prized
possession was her voice and they took
that from her as they ended her life
while the townspeople expected that this
would be the end of it it was only the
beginning of the terror that she
unleashed on the town which started with
a strange set of requests documented in
mary's will
in today's world we're relying more and
more on the internet as part of our
daily lives
people are working from home and making
purchases online but often don't think
about the safety of their sensitive info
that's why i recommend nordvpn
when you're not using nordvpn isps
governments and hackers can see exactly
what you're doing online but by
connecting to nord's fast and secure
servers your data will be encrypted
twice as it travels through the cloud so
your privacy is protected i think it's
something that every single internet
user should have to stay safe online
with my deal you're gonna be able to get
nordvpn for as low as 350 per month with
a three year plan which is already worth
it to protect yourself but also it pays
for itself with what you can do with it
as a horror movie fan nordvpn is a dream
let's say i want to watch jigsaw nope
not on netflix or at least not on
netflix in my country but i bet it's
available in another country so i'll
just look it up change to this canadian
server and there it is i saved another
10 bucks you can do the same thing on
geolocked youtube videos to open up a
whole new world
of content all you need to do to get
started is visit nordvpn.comworld with
my link they're giving you 70
off a three-year plan plus one month for
free all it takes is one click for
online security that's nordvpn.comworld
the contents of mary shaw's will
revealed two very unorthodox requests
the first was that she wanted each of
her 101 dolls to be buried alongside her
at the ravens fair cemetery the second
which was perhaps even more unusual was
the request that she herself be turned
into another life-sized doll
the method by which mary became a spirit
is not detailed in the movie but we do
at least see that her ghost has the
ability to possess the ventriloquist
dolls and give them one of her voices
or the voice of one of the victims whose
tongue she removed it's a bit unclear if
mary is an apparition as opposed to a
wandering spirit that needs a vessel
or a physical entity that comes back
from the dead we see examples of all
three in the movie which does feel like
a cop out at times but i think we're
supposed to assume that it's all three
she spends most of her time in human
form but she'll take over the dolls from
time to time and she can also just
disappear entirely if she wants to
the first time she used her newfound
powers was not long after her death in
1941.
henry the son of the town's mortician
had snuck into the room containing her
coffin and accidentally knocked it over
her corpse fell on top of him and then
she yelled out
john cena
he tries scrambling away and when he
looked back she was no longer there but
rather
standing upright on the side of the room
and she began to come for him it wasn't
until his father came in and turned on
the lights that she disappeared and the
room went back to normal or at least as
normal as a room can look when it
contains an old lady who got her tongue
cut out and then requested to be turned
into a human-sized doll it seems that
light is actually a weakness of hers and
this may be related to how she was in
life where part of the illusion that
made her act work was that she was
silhouetted in darkness while the
spotlight was on billy so that the
audience would be less likely to look at
her and possibly see her lips moving
many ghosts and unrest spirits linger
because they have some kind of mission
that must be fulfilled in order for them
to rest in peace
and in mary's case it is to silence all
those who silenced her
to silence all those who silenced
me from this point forward each of the
men involved in her murder were killed
one by one after which she came after
their families she started with the
wives then went after the children
and in some cases also took out their
grandchildren as well the people started
to realize a pattern though just as
light seemed to be her weakness because
of the way
she was in life the act of screaming is
her strength probably as a statement of
revenge for the brutal manner in which
she was killed
a legend circulated in the area
beware the stare of mary shaw she had no
children
only dolls something was something
scary something though
most of the victims were unable to
resist screaming while being terrorized
by mary's ghost and the families of the
deceased were left behind in photogenic
arrangements with no tongues the
remaining families in town quickly
dwindled but through all of this
there was one man who refused to scream
during mary shaw's hauntings
and his name is john c
well that's twice i've done that joke
now so you know there's probably only
going to be one more
the man's name was edward ashen but how
did he manage to avoid mary's curse if
he was only a child at the time
my theory is that the spirit of mary
wasn't always as thorough as she is now
if this is the case then the ghost of
mary shaw could have overlooked the last
member of the ashen family because he
was still in the womb at the time
a mistake she made sure not to make
further down the line edward would have
been raised with all of the warnings and
legends in town teaching him not to
scream if he ever saw her and by the
time she discovered the existence of a
brother in the ashen family it was too
late and she would have to find a more
clever way to get him to scream but as
she took out the other families the
legend continued to grow and people
became cautious about ever muttering her
name
if only they had known you can get
around that by just saying she who must
not be named or
the dark lord they would also avoid
going near her grave by the 1980s most
of the potential victims were either
dead or had learned how to get by safely
and no new murders took place
kids in town began to see the poem
beware the stare of mary shaw is more of
an urban legend rather than an actual
legitimate warning so some parents began
to send their kids away to live in the
city fearing that the town was still
cursed
as a result the place fell into a state
of disarray during the 90s with no one
there to run the shops the place was
basically only occupied by the older
generation who couldn't bring themselves
to leave so she seems to disappear for a
number of years but once she does
eventually return to finish the job a
local woman named marion the wife of
henry from all those years ago who seems
to have abilities as a medium
senses the return of the vengeful sprite
she hides in a crawlspace repeating the
phrase the silent time is here which
ironically is exactly what ticketmaster
says whenever you try to get a refund
for cancelled shows
mary as far as we know only has a few
targets remaining she wants to finish
taking out the family of michael ash
the one that first silenced her all of
those years ago she had already tried
and failed to get a scream from edward
ashen and his son jaime had been sent
away as a boy
jaime also had a child on the way and
this time mary was not going to let an
unborn offspring escape she started by
taking a new approach with edward who
had now been through two divorces so
mary transformed herself into ella who
presumably slid into edward's dms until
she became the third wife unsuspecting
of her true nature he was eventually
caught off guard and turned into the
next perfect doll or life-size
ventriloquist dummy it's unknown if this
was at the same time as the stroke
mentioned in the movie or if that was
just entirely fabricated
what happened to you your father had a
stroke two months ago
the next victim would be jaime's unborn
child which was bad news for the wife
that was carrying it
since jamie was starting his family in
the city away from ravens fair ella
slash mary packed billy in a box and
sent him on his way to infiltrate
jaime's apartment which makes a lot more
sense than in child's play 3 where
chucky somehow packs and sends himself
all while inside the box
a good guy the package is addressed to
jaime who leaves his wife alone to go
pick up takeout
using billy the puppet she takes out
lisa starting by sucking all of the
sound out of the apartment luring her
into the bedroom where billy is using a
playful laughter sound and
startling her with a sudden scream
before taking her out and ensuring that
the child she was carrying can never be
born
when jaime gets back she tries to do the
same to him by using the newly acquired
voice of lisa to lure him into the room
the sight of what had been done to his
wife is not enough to draw a stream out
of him and he ends up heading home to
ravens fair to plan her funeral and
search for answers of his own
he gets to his father's house to ask
about mary shaw but mary taking the form
of ella answers the door instead and
tries to throw him off by saying that
the legend of mary shaw was just the
story that parents made up to scare kids
like the boogeyman
or the pink guy that night at jaime's
motel she tries once again to get him by
sucking all the sound out of the room
and speaking to him before he falls
asleep when he wakes up
she appears before him but he's able to
turn the light on causing her to
disappear before he screams
the next night is her third attempt this
time she uses the billy doll to make the
graveyard go silent as he's attempting
to bury it and turns the doll's head
suddenly but it's still not enough to
get him
as he's leaving she circles around the
car laughing as she does so and tries to
surprise him by holding up the now
unearthed doll to his car window but is
able to get no more than a gasp
after three failures she realizes that
she's dealing with the son of edward
ashen and she's gonna have to do
something much more grand if she wants
to get a scream from him so she digs up
the other 100 dolls from the graveyard
after one more failed jump scare attempt
involving a mirror while jaime's
investigating the theater during the day
she abandons the idea of using cheap
scares and begins to build a more
elaborate trap her plan involved using
the voice of henry walker one of the few
men left alive from the heyday of the
town but henry's wife marion makes
contact with her first which is part of
why i think that she has medium
abilities we don't see this scene
directly but we do hear it from the
other room and if we turn up the volume
we can hear marion begging mary to leave
her husband
it what do you alone we did what you
wanted
we put you in there with your family all
together
why can't you just leave us alone
marian claims that she hasn't done
anything wrong but mary shaw seems to
think differently
miriam's pleads are not enough to sway
the evil spirit who then goes dead
silent
because you know name of the movie when
henry discovers his wife talking to the
doll he fears the return of the curse
and decides it's best to rebury it but
before he has the chance to do so he
hears
a crying sound which he thinks is his
wife down in the crawl space
as it turns out it is not marian but
rather mary who locks him under the
house he probably knows he's done for
after hearing a greeting from billy's
voice and seeing mary shaw's three weeks
expired sausage looking fingers creeping
around the pillar so he screams and mary
takes his tongue
and subsequently his voice and uses it
to lure jaime back to the theater with
the promise of more information about
lisa's killer
another creepy detail about mary shaw in
ghost form is her tongue which allows us
to see just how many victims she's taken
the voices of each additional one is
tacked on
creating a long and horrifying strand
that's one a haygow face that i never
want to see
when jaime and the detective arrive at
the theater mary possesses a clown doll
to speak to jaime and tell him that the
baby that his wife was carrying was her
real target
i think her new strategy is to get an
emotional reaction out of him rather
than just simply trying to startle him
the first emotion that she goes for is
anger and when that doesn't work she
goes for fear by possessing the 100
and making them do freaky stuff that
looks like it should be in an episode of
courage the cowardly dog they burn the
display of dolls and try to escape but
mary takes another victim by getting a
scream out of the detective
she almost gets jaime but he catches
himself and escapes to go take care of
the last doll
billy which had been left at the funeral
home i think mary was anticipating this
move and she had one last trick up her
sleeve to try to trick him into letting
out a scream in order for it to work she
needed to get him to go back to the
ashen house so she possesses edward's
body to go and take the billy doll from
the funeral
home in the overheard conversation
between marion and mary
without the n mary shaw is upset with
her because she's supposedly talked
which presumably means that she warned
jaime about the curse when she wasn't
supposed to
interestingly she's left alive and i
think it's all part of mary's plan
she knows that mrs walker will talk
again and tell jaime that his father
came and took the doll which will
eventually lead him back home where ella
aka
mary shaw will be waiting for him i mean
i don't know why it has to be there but
yeah i never claimed this one was
perfect so that is exactly what happens
it ends up being the shock of finding
that his father was a puppet all along
and his stepmom was the one controlling
him that finally coerces a scream from
him and after collecting his tongue
she's now able to close her scrapbook
after having created dolls of the whole
ash and family
we can assume that mary's spirit can
rest easy after that the only survivor
is marion and it's not hard to imagine
that mary shaw would come after her next
having outlived her usefulness
and seeing how there hasn't been another
movie since then i would have to assume
that means mary's spirit has had its
fill of revenge and can finally move on
but to be fair there isn't really any
confirmation that there aren't survivors
from any of the other families and if
there are i'm sure we'll see mary shaw
rise up once again
remember to subscribe to cece's world
for new horrors every week ring that
death bell for john c
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we stay inside
[Music]